[Applause]
only cowards beat women
shout hundreds of women as they face
down the police
but the authorities no longer want to
let this weekly march go ahead
unchallenged police barely seemed to
hesitate as they packed women into their
trucks
even 73 year old nina bahinskaya was
briefly detained
her defiance of the authorities has made
her an icon of these protests
overwhelmingly led by women
it was scary at the beginning but then
you get used to it
what can you do i'm more scared about
living with the feeling that i did
nothing when all this was happening in
my country
the crackdown is getting harsher by the
day and there is still little sign the
riot police are deserting president
alexander lukashenko
who demonstrators say rigged the august
9 presidential election
what is democracy it's when the majority
has voted for the president
[Music]
no nobody voted for him
women taking part in opposition rallies
now not only have to fear for their
safety
but also that of their children
authorities have been threatening
to remove children from protester
parents
a warning that's only been fueling the
anger on the streets
and dw correspondent nick connolly has
been covering those protests for several
weeks now for us he joins us
from minsk uh nick what can we expect
from today's rally
well we're expecting tens if not
hundreds of thousands of people out on
the streets
of minsk for yet another weekend that
election that rigged election over a
month
passed now and these protests showing no
sign of ending anytime soon the police
has come out
in force today huge presence in terms of
technology in terms of trucks
also vans to take people away that is
the pattern of the past few weeks so
definitely an attempt
to intimidate the protesters also to
keep them out of the city centre where i
am now
force them out into the suburbs maybe
break down the protest groups to make it
easier to make arrests
but if these last few weeks have been a
sign of anything it's that
every time the government ups the
pressure on the protesters they just
bring out more people against them
and we just heard in the report that
security forces are targeting
women why is that
well i think these women's marches
women's demonstrations even if they
haven't been as big as the sunday
demonstrations they really have
played a very important role in social
media they've inspired a lot of people
the women they're very keen to show that
protests can be safe that protests can
be
without violence bringing their children
bringing flowers trying to create a
different atmosphere the government here
has tried to cast protesters violent
attempts to
interfere in belarus affairs something
that people nor ordinary people should
keep away from
and i think their example is really
infectious i was walking with them
yesterday and you saw people
standing on their balconies waving
flowers surprised that the protests had
come
out into the suburbs where they live
that protest is not just something they
see on their
phone screens their tv screens but
something that can happen in real
everyday life
and the most impressive thing for me or
surprising even was that after those
arrests we saw in the report
the women who were left didn't leave
that spot they just stayed so about half
an hour later the police had to come
back and arrest yet more people
i think they seemed themselves shocked
that those pretty violent arrests had
not had a chilling effect on them and
they were just
willing to keep on standing there and
basically stare the police down
all right dw's nick connolly in thanks
for that reporting
you